differentiation is everywhere in science
and engineering
in machine learning we need derivatives
when we use gradient-based optimization
for example in gradient descent where we
attempt to minimize some objective
function
by repeatedly tuning our model's
parameters in the direction of the
negative gradient
in this video we'll try to understand
the basic idea behind
automatic differentiation or autodiff
a set of techniques that allow us to
compute derivatives efficiently
help if we first contrast autodip with
some other ways of computing derivatives
one way what we might think to do from
high school calculus
is to look at our function and manually
differentiate it using our basic
derivative rules
we could simply code up the result and
call it a day but this can be a fairly
tedious process for more
complicated functions we generally
prefer an automated approach
now automatic differentiation as its
name suggests
is one of these but it's not the only
one
another is numerical differentiation
which uses the method of finite
differences
to approximate derivatives the simplest
version intuitively follows from the
limit definition of the derivative
say we have a scalar valued function f
for a partial derivative with respect to
x
i we set up a quotient where in the
numerator
we subtract two evaluations of the
function at nearby points
x plus h e i and x e i
is just the unit vector along the i axis
and h is a step size
typically a small fraction so while this
can be fairly simple to implement
some issues come up with accuracy and
numerical stability
one issue is truncation error
we're trying to approximate a limit as h
goes to zero but we're using some
non-zero h
what we're really calculating is the
slope of a secant line near the tangent
line at x
as h gets closer to zero and the secant
line approaches the tangent line
the truncation error decreases this
eventually leads to what's called
rounding error due to the limited
precision of floating point arithmetic
so we have to carefully consider this
trade-off between truncation and
rounding here
when selecting a step size now in
machine learning
especially in the context of say
training neural networks
some approximation error may be okay
after all stochastic gradient descent
only uses a noisy estimation of the true
gradient
the bigger problem with numerical
differentiation here is that we need o
of n evaluations for an n-dimensional
gradient
this time complexity simply won't cut it
when we have a model with millions of
parameters
another approach is symbolic
differentiation which is essentially an
automated version of the manual
differentiation we looked at before
we hand a closed form version of our
function to a symbolic differentiation
program
that applies the standard derivative
rules transforming the original
expression into the derivative of
interest
this bypasses the sources of error we
saw in numerical differentiation
allowing exact computation of
derivatives up to numerical precision
but it comes with its own difficulties
one problem is known as
expression swell where derivative
expressions may be
exponentially longer than the original
function
why does this happen well some
derivative rules
like say the product rule naturally lead
to duplicated computation
any computation shared between f and f
prime here will be executed twice
if f itself involved a product of
functions this would be further
exacerbated
for example let's look at this
recurrence relation known as the
logistic map
for n equals 1 and 2 the derivative
expression is about as simple as the
original
but as we increase n further the
derivative quickly gets out of hand
now in this example we can simplify the
expression quite a bit
to polynomial form but this isn't always
possible
consider this function known as soft
relu a common activation function in
neural networks
even two of these composed together
leads to a fairly involved derivative
symbolically differentiating through a
network of many layers
is usually not tenable in addition
symbolic differentiation requires our
function to be expressed in closed form
limiting our ability to use control flow
mechanisms like conditionals
loops and recursion automatic
differentiation computes derivatives
with the same accuracy as symbolic
but operates directly on the program of
interest
rather than produce an expression for a
derivative the sole intent of autodiv is
to obtain its numerical value
it bypasses symbolic inefficiency by
leveraging intermediate variables
present in the original function's
implementation
and more easily handles control flow the
basic idea is that
ultimately implemented differentiable
functions are composed of underlying
primitive operations whose derivatives
we know
and the chain rule allows us to compose
these together
there are two main versions of autodiff
forward mode and reverse mode
we'll first take a look at forward mode
the conceptually simpler of the two
forward autodiff involves augmenting
each intermediate variable during
evaluation of a function with its
derivative
so instead of individual floating point
values flowing through a function
we can think of these as being replaced
by tuples of the original intermediate
values
also called primals paired with their
derivatives also known as tangents
say we're interested in this function we
have two scalar inputs
x1 and x2 and a single scalar output
we noticed some repeated use of certain
sub-expressions which would likely
influence how we implement it
we start with our two input variables
which we'll denote with v negative one
and v
zero as we proceed we evaluate
intermediate variables
some of which will be used more than
once in later computations
and we eventually reach the final
function output
now suppose we'd like to compute the
partial derivative of this function with
respect to x1
at the point x1 equals 1.5 and x2 equals
0.5
in addition to computation of the
primals we simultaneously compute
their tangent values that is each
evaluation of an intermediate variable
vi
will now be accompanied by the value of
partial bi
partial x1 a single pass through the
function now produces
not only the original output but the
partial derivative of interest
[Music]
this example function only has a single
scalar output
suppose it had multiple forward mode
autodiff allows us to compute the
partial derivatives
of each of these outputs with respect to
an input variable
all in a single forward pass which is
great
the catch is that we have to run a
separate forward pass for each input
variable of interest
for this example function we'd have to
follow the same procedure again
to get partials with respect to x2
consider general functions from rn to rm
each pass of forward mode autodiv
produces one
column of the corresponding jacobian
this starts to give us a hint about when
we might like to use forward mode
we'll see that relative to reverse mode
forward mode is generally preferred
for computing jacobians where n is much
less than m
that is we have few inputs and many
outputs
notice in our example that we
initialized x dot 2
1 0 since we wanted the partial
derivative with respect to x x1
but partial derivatives are just the
axis aligned special case
of more general directional derivatives
we can initialize x dot to any unit
vector we'd like
and compute the corresponding
directional derivative with a single
forward pass more generally
we can actually compute jacobian vector
products
without ever computing the jacobian
matrix itself
we set x dot to the vector of interest
and proceed with forward mode autodiv
now this seems a little weird right
after all we
just said that forward mode requires one
pass through the function
for each input well we can basically
think of the jacobian vector product
as just the jacobian of a different
function the composition
of our original function and one with a
single scalar input
whose jacobian is the column vector r
because the overall jacobian of this
composed function
now only has one column we see why a
single forward pass
is sufficient there are several ways to
go about actually implementing
forward mode auditive one route perhaps
the simplest implement
is to leverage operator overloading
where we abstract away the actual
derivative computation
instead of operating on raw floats we
write a simple class with attributes
denoting the values of both the primal
and its tangent
we could then overload the primitive
arithmetic operations
to additionally handle derivative
computation
for example for the addition operation
we typically just take the two raw
values and
add them together instead we'll include
the simple sum rule for derivatives
and set the dot attribute of the
returned object accordingly
we would do the same for the other
operators allowing us to implement the
overall function just as we normally
would
except this time the values of both the
original function
and its derivative are produced another
general route is known as
source code transformation where input
source code is actually manipulated to
produce a new function
this can be more efficient than operator
overloading as it directly exposes the
logic
of the new source code to the compiler
but it's a bit more difficult to
implement
i'll provide links in the description
for further details about
different kinds of implementations as
well as example software libraries
now we saw that forward mode autodiff
looks like a good route when there are
only a few inputs that we're interested
in partial derivatives for
but in the context of machine learning
we usually don't meet this condition
in fact we're typically in the scenario
where we have a model with many
parameters
even numbering into the billions these
days and we'd like the gradient of a
scalar loss
with respect to these parameters reverse
mode autodiff allows us to handle this
case efficiently
rather than propagating derivatives
forward they'll be propagated backwards
from the output
this is carried out in a two-part
process we first start with a forward
pass through the function
evaluating intermediate variables as we
did before
but instead of simultaneously computing
derivatives we store the dependencies of
the expression tree in memory
then after completion of the forward
pass we compute partial derivatives of
the output
with respect to the intermediate
variables quantities known as adjoints
which we'll denote with v bar to obtain
the adjoint v bar i
for a particular node we look at each of
the nodes children
multiply the adjoint of the child by the
partial derivative of the child
with respect to vi and then take the sum
of these products
so vi's contribution to the final output
is determined both by how each of its
children
affect the output and how it affects
each of its children
at the end we obtain partial derivatives
with respect to each input
so the gradient is computed with just a
single execution of reverse mode
auditive
making it far better suited to the
typical optimization setting in
machine learning in the context of
neural networks
the back propagation algorithm which is
used to compute derivatives with respect
to network weights
may be viewed as a special case of
reverse mode autodiv
where the adjoints with respect to
intermediate layer activations
are propagated backwards through the
network
for general vector valued functions
reverse mode produces
one row of the jacobian at a time making
it ideal when we have few outputs
relative to inputs
now for both forward and reverse mode
what's especially neat is that a single
pass does not take much longer than
evaluating the function itself in fact
computing a single column
of the jacobian and forward mode or a
single row in reverse mode
is guaranteed to take less than six
times the number of operations in the
original function implementation
in practice it tends to only be about
two or three times
reverse mode is usually a bit more
memory intensive than forward
we have to store the values of
intermediate variables and their
dependencies
in memory various techniques have been
developed that help make this more
efficient
including re-materialization where only
a subset are stored
and the remainder are recomputed during
the backwards pass
forward and reverse mode are the two
extremes of automatic differentiation
but in some settings a hybrid approach
is actually preferred
for example in second order optimization
where information about an objective
function's curvature
is taken into account a hessian vector
product is sometimes needed
a reverse on forward version of autodiff
allows efficient computation of this
product
first we use forward mode to compute the
directional derivative gradient f
times v by setting x dot to v as we did
before
then reverse mode is used to
differentiate again resulting in the
hessian times v
as with the jacobian vector product
we're able to compute the hessian vector
product without explicitly computing the
hessian matrix itself
in general we can compute arbitrarily
higher order derivatives
by composing multiple executions of
autodiv together
so automatic differentiation helps make
life much easier
when we need to obtain derivatives of
complicated functions it's not always
applicable
but when we can directly implement a
function of interest in code
this set of techniques allows accurate
computation of its derivatives with
minimal overhead
autodiv has a rich history and ongoing
research continues to improve it
check out the links in the description
to learn more thanks for watching